well it's officially september which
means fall is upon us but sometimes
making that transition out of summer
takes a bit of an adjustment so here to
give us her tips as we fall into a new
season you see what i did there
it's angela giles the co-founder of
everyday angela thank you so much for
being here well thank you so much i'm
excited to be here it's going to be
really fun chatting about this yeah i
think everyone is ready to make that
transition into fall but you have some
really important tips five key things to
keep in mind and keep your productivity
up as we transition into the new season
so let's talk about some of those well i
think my first tip is you know when
i always think of after labor day school
starts you have to get back into this
like you know schedule and do all these
things right so my first tip is have fun
with it
right i mean find fun i always tell
everyone find 15 minutes a day where
you're enjoying your life whatever that
is talking to your bff you know sitting
in a hot bath going for a walk whatever
that looks like i think is is my number
one tip and you're a mom of three boys
right boys yes so you have your hands
full you know how to juggle everything
how do you keep the kids on track too
when making those transitions i mean i
think that we have fun like i'm always
about making fun making time for fun i'm
also all about having a schedule where
you know you're getting enough rest i
think it's so important that your kids
get enough rest whether they're small
kids or you know teenagers young adults
even your own body you need to adjust
and fluctuate i need more rest right now
than i do in the peak of the summer
right it's it's true because the more
stress you're under the more rest you
need and speaking of adjustments i think
one of the hardest adjustments is when
we change the clocks and it's dark in
the mornings or gets dark earlier in the
evenings it's cold that's a whole
different change on your body so what
tips do you have to stay motivated as we
transition into those darker evenings
and colder mornings well you know what's
so interesting for me it's always
finding my thing that i enjoy so for
example this may sound crazy i'm an avid
reader i love reading so at nights i
reward myself with a cup of tea
and i get to sit down with my iphone and
i pick a book and i love to read so it's
all about going back to the basics
sometimes finding that thing if you have
a favorite food you love another thing
that i'm a huge advocate of is a sun
lamp right especially where if you
struggle with some sort of seasonal
thing i happen to you know most of my
life and so a sun lamp is really awesome
for me making sure you get out and get
enough sunshine because it helps your
production you know your vitamin d and
helps you stay motivated yeah absolutely
and in las vegas we're so used to sun
all the time and then when that's gone
it's a big adjustment for it's huge you
don't recognize it well thank you so
much for all the tips and if anyone
wants to read more or learn more where
can they find you you know what just
find us on everyday woman is our brand
we have a huge community of over 14 000
women just look for us on facebook you
can go to everydaywoman.me and check it
out we have all kinds of tips for women
so well thank you so much angela we're
all excited for fall so thank you for
all the tips i'll send it over to
mercedes